it's 1200 GMT that's 300 p.m. in Gaza
this is the scene there you can still
see smoke Rising above the skyline
hospitals there are being overwhelmed
there's a severe shortage of supplies as
Israel continues its bombardment on this
densely populated Enclave at least 3,700
Palestinians have been injured more than
200 of them children gaza's Health
Ministry has accused Israel of targeting
its ambulances injuring paramedics and a
food crisis is also looming the UN says
it's been forced to close all 14 food
distribution centers and that affects
half a million people let's go to Jamila
Abu Zuna she's live for us in Gaza and
Jamila you're outside the alifa hospital
it was another long night of ferocious
air strikes all over the Gaza Strip what
is the scene there this
morning
yes uh we have just uh finished the uh
uh press conference of the uh uh
director of government uh media office
Dr sal sal Maru who has filled us with
the updates of the increasing numbers of
the uh casualties in Gaza so we have a
total number of more than
765 dead and um 8,000 highly injured uh
in asifa hospital he's also announced a
total number of uh 168 buildings of
residential buildings and towers that
were targeted in the bom bombardment uh
for the last 3 days and until today uh
it's also important to mention that this
is the fourth day and by tomorrow there
will be a complete shutdown of Power
with no water uh no food and nothing no
supplies at all and the Israeli
airplanes have um air Jets have shot and
attacked the uh Rafa cross cross point
today uh with multiple um with multiple
uh Rockets so there's no way to to come
out or to receive any help from the
outside uh we have today with um in our
company Dr
midhat midhat abas we have a couple of
questions to ask you for the situation
in Gaza what do you think of what's
happening and what do you expect for the
next couple of
days well I'm I'm not so optimistic in
fact what happened prior to this prior
to this crisis we have had shortage of
medications medical supplies and
reagents required to operate the
Laboratories of our Hospital in fact uh
uh so the situation was very hard and
complicated then after this crisis we
are receiving we have received thousands
of the injured as you see this is
pressurizing the Ministry of Health
staff and health facilities especially
that all the bid capacities our capacity
uh in the hospitals is only some 2,000
bids for that reason 2,000 bids with
more than 2,000 injured it means that we
are about to collapse the other thing is
that with shortage of medication we are
consuming today in one day what in the
ordinary days we consume in one month
for that reason
uh we we should have enough medications
right now at once those medications and
medical supplies will be used in the
operation rooms intensive care units and
in the Laboratories and in the emergency
rooms at time on the other hand the
situation is so bad five ambulances are
attacked till this moment and five of
our colleagues are killed already
there's no safe route for the health
professionals to move between hospitals
and their homes on the other hand health
facilities are being attacked like Naser
hospital they have attacked one of the
amb Ulan is inside the premises of Nas
hospital and Bon all the city of bhon is
totally annihilated including Banning
the work inside the Bon only Hospital
existing at this area uh the the problem
of electricity now was coincident with
this crisis so we have no electricity
now in hospitals and we are relying on
standby generators consuming a lot of
fuel some 800,000 liters of diesel
required every month we do not have
enough fuel at the same time the Border
are SE so we cannot bring inside any
additional fuel uh I think uh without
opening the borders now freely for extra
patients to travel abroad without
stopping this war against civilians in
Gaza Strip without having medications
medical supplies right now we will be
having a very big problem and I'm afraid
sry to say that the health system will
collapsing G the
strip thank you you're
welcome I leave it to you uh after
hearing uh what's been happening at Gaza
in the lat latest news uh and we have
no we have no expected scenario in the
next couple of hours or days okay Jam
Abu Zuna bringing us the latest there
from outside alifa Hospital in Gaza